جميع الضحاياها كنا من النساء المسنات
قتلت العشرات منهن بيديها العاريتين دون
استخدام اي وسيله او سلاح معتمده على
قوتها البدنيه الكبيره حتى باتت تعرف في
بلادها بسفاحه العجائز
الاسم جوانا برازا
تهمه قاتله متسلسله
المكان المكسيك
الحكم السجن المؤبد
في السادس والعشرين من يناير عام 2006
اعلنت الشرطه المكسيكيه عن خبر طال
انتظارهم القينا القبض على اخطر قاتل
متسلسل في البلاد لكن المفاجاه كانت ان
هذا القاتل وعلى عكس ما اشارت اليه جميع
التحقيقات لم يكن رجلا بل كان امراه
مصارعه محترفه سابقه ترتدي قناعا امام
خصومها وتلقب نفسها بالسيده الصامته انها
جوانا بارازا القاتله المتسلسله التي
اعجزت الشرطه والمحققين لسنوات طويله
ازهقت بارازا ارواح عشرات من الضحايا بين
عام
1993 عام 2006 كانت تستهدف النساء المسنات
اللواتي يعيشن وحدهن على وجه الخصوص تطرق
ابوابهن مدعيه انها مندوبه من برامج
الرعايه الاجتماعيه وبعد ان تكسب ثقتهن
للدخول تخنقه او تضربهن حتى يفارقنا
الحياه معتمده بذلك على قوتها الجسديه
الكبيره بسبب مهنتها السابقه في المصارعه
ثم بعد ذلك تسرق ما خف وزنه وغلا تمنه
وتفر هاربه كان البحث عن براز معقدا
للغايه حيث افترض المحققون كل تلك السنوات
ان القاتل كان رجلا بسبب طريقه قتل
الضحايا التي تحتاج الى قوه جسديه كبيره
كما ان جميع الشهود اشاروا الى مشاهدتهم
شخصا ببنيه ضخمه واكتاف عريضه
يعتقد ان دافع برازا لتلك الجرائم البشعه
كان رغبتها في الانتقام من جميع النسوه
المسنات فوالدتها التي كانت مدمنه على
الكحول سلمتها عندما كانت طفله لرجل قام
باغتصادها حتى انها كانت هادئه جدا خلال
التحقيقات ولم تبدي ايا من علامات
الارتباك او الندم
48 امراه مسنه مع انها اعترفت بثلاث جرائم
منها فقط وحكم عليها بالسجن لمده
759 عاما فيما اثارت قضيتها غضبا واسعا في
المكسيك فرغم ان البلاد معروفه بارتفاع
معدل الجرائم والعنف الى انها من النادر
ان تسجل جرائم لقتله متسلسلين خصوصا اذا
كان الجاني فيها ليس رجلا